I'm here at the MTV Movie and TV Awards
for Comedy Central and I'm going to
interview everyone not even just the
celebrities like everybody on the carpet
like that guy that's like that girl
she's not celeb Rihanna does she's
probably like somebody's bodyguard hey
who are you interested to see oh my god
everybody everybody what a terrible
answer that was not specific at all you
want to such a cop's good side where do
you want to touch and it spat in his
face
this is this gonna be a fun day overall
I will you sound like you're having the
best night you've ever had this is gonna
be the best night I want my best outfit
okay okay I think it's red enough we're
just like the fast and furious we're fam
I've never seen that movie we got to
make sure everybody's clean for the
celebrities this is a big attend I've
ever seen for the celebrity for the
celebrities I guess I'm confused about
your job do you sell dress no I don't go
there somebody told me you are confused
thank you all right well if you get
drugs call me okay okay all right you
guys are clean enough you can touch the
celebrity you guys can't I haven't
gotten to you yet there's five hot dogs
do you eat burgers sometimes I thought
about my red meat today because it's our
ankhon night I got a hair that's that's
as part of it do you find a lot of hair
in your which I made a wish based on
what you wish for just world peace every
time I have to did you wear the white so
you could do the wet t-shirt contest in
this ring yeah obviously I've been
working on my ABS so
Sam for Comedy Central we'd like to
laugh at them as fast it's furious
that's how I live my life go run run run
run